cuál es la ecuación de la línea
horizontal que pasa por menos 46 vamos a
visualizar esto y una vez que se
familiaricen con esto no va a ser
necesario que dibuje en estas gráficas
pero ahorita vamos a usarla para
ayudarnos a visualizar esto este es mi
eje de las x este es mi eje de las yes y
-4 en el eje x va a estar por acá
1-2-3-4 aquí está menos cuatro y ahora
seis en la dirección y va a estar aquí y
nuestro punto de interés va a estar
justo aquí menos 46 y nos preguntan cuál
es la ecuación de la línea horizontal
que pasa por este punto así que aquí
está mi línea horizontal que pasa por
este punto cuál será su ecuación bueno
para cualquier valor de x el valor en g
va a ser igual a 6 así que esto tiene
ecuación ye igual a 6 ya que no importa
qué valor tengamos para x
y siempre va a tener valor igual a 6 se
mantiene constante aquí así que la
respuesta es igual a 6 hagamos otro
problema nos preguntan cuál es la
pendiente de la línea y igual a menos 4
nuevamente dibujamos nuestros ejes para
ayudarnos a visualizar qué es lo que
pasa pero una vez que ustedes se
familiaricen con esto no van a tener que
dibujar estas gráficas aquí tenemos el
eje x aquí está el eje y y la pendiente
de la línea de igual a menos 4 cuál será
pues para cualquier valor que tengamos
de x que siempre va a ser igual a menos
4 aquí lo dibujamos menos 4 ya igual a
menos 4 así que aquí está nuestra línea
de igual a menos 4 y cuál será la
pendiente la pendiente es el cambio en
que con respecto al cambio en x y aquí
no importa cuál sea mi cambio en x
mi que siempre permanece constante no
cambia el cambio en que con respecto al
cambio en x en este caso no importa cuál
sea el cambio en x me va a ser constante
el cambio en cero porque no cambia así
que aquí la pendiente va a ser igual a
cero no importa cuánto cambie x ya nunca
va a cambiar
hagamos otro problema ahora nos
preguntan cuál es la pendiente de la
línea x igual a menos tres nuevamente
dibujamos nuestros ejes ahora nos
preguntan cuál es la pendiente de la
línea x igual a menos 3 y cuál es mi
línea x igual a menos 3
aquí tenemos menos 1 - 2 - 3 vamos a
dibujar esta línea con este color y aquí
no importa qué valor tenga ye x siempre
va a ser igual a menos 3 así que esta
línea luce así y cuál será su pendiente
pues no está definida una línea vertical
tiene una pendiente no definida
recuerden que la pendiente es el cambio
en ye con respecto al cambio en x y
bueno podrían pensar en cuál es la
pendiente conforme nos aproximamos a
este valor y algunas personas podrían
decir bueno se acerca infinito o bueno
se acerca a menos infinito pero es
justamente por eso que no está definida
una línea vertical va a tener una p
no definida así que esta es nuestra
opción correcta hagamos otro problema
cuál es la ecuación de la línea vertical
qué pasa por menos cinco menos dos voy a
resolver esta pregunta primero sin
dibujar la gráfica y después la dibujaré
si estamos hablando de una línea
vertical significa que x no va a cambiar
x no cambia si hablamos de una línea
horizontal entonces sería de la que no
cambia entonces si x no cambia quiere
decir que x va a ser igual a un valor
constante y si esta línea contiene al
punto menos 5 menos 2 entonces quiere
decir que x es igual a menos 5 ya que es
constante así que la ecuación de esta
línea es x igual a menos 5 porque es una
línea vertical y x nunca cambia ahora
vamos a graficar la aquí están mis ejes
mi eje x mi eje ii y ahora dibujamos el
punto menos cinco menos dos tenemos
menos 1 2 3 4 5 y menos 12 así que este
punto se encuentra justo aquí y nuestra
línea vertical va a lucir así
y noten que x nunca cambia no importa
qué valor tenga x siempre va a ser el
mismo es igual a menos 5 y va a tener
una pendiente no definida y la ecuación
de esta línea es x igual a menos 5